when the Sun sets on Soho in central
london britain shows its most liberal
side here there's a place for straight
gay lesbian and everything in between
since march of this year gays and
lesbians in england and wales can get
legally married just like heterosexuals
but that doesn't necessarily make life
easy for all of them especially for many
gays and lesbians from britain's more
traditional immigrant families
on an early Friday evening I met up with
SAR warm a gay Muslim his family comes
from East Africa he wanted to bring me
here to the River Thames to a Gay and
Lesbian Film Festival SAR war says being
a part of a gay community is important
to him it means that you feel you part
of a larger family people of the same
sexual orientation people may feel
excluded from the general community but
they can be in this family and also
share ideas and not feel lonely it can
be a lonely place sometimes sorrow war
has been coming to the festival almost
every day usually his partner nigel is
with him the two have been a couple for
17 years today they're attending a
showing of an indian bollywood classic
after the movie Nigel tells me it took a
while for the two of them to fall in
love it was it was lust at first sight
so it was later though I think when we
were going out and we went out for four
days the chemistry was definitely there
but there were problems with Sarah
where's family who live in northern
England they still don't accept her
sexuality I never wanted to go out with
someone who wasn't out and open about
themselves in their relation
but there was something different about
sawa there was something that made me
think actually maybe I should compromise
but it wasn't it didn't feel like a real
compromise because so I was out in
London living a gay man's life in London
sir Warren Nigel are planning to tie the
knot later this year Nigel's family will
attend the wedding as will the cobbles
many friends but sarwar doesn't know
about his siblings my oldest is who
would not attend because you Ivan had
contact with this is my mother passed
away because I'm my brother-in-law and
I'm not sure about other families out
would invite them and he's their choice
later in the nights are war and Nigel
head to club cali a gay and lesbian like
club that specializes in indian and arab
beats many of DJ ritu's regular guests
are of Southeast Asian heritage
she opened the club nearly 20 years ago
I would have hoped that in the almost
two decades that we've run in club been
running club Carly that but by now we
would see lots of changes and shifts and
many more young people feeling able to
be out everywhere and that's not the
case at all DJ Rita says many of the
club goers here still face exclusion
from their families from society at
large and even from other gays and
lesbians there is a degree of racism
within the LGBT scene scene there's
there's not necessarily full acceptance
of people that are other than the norm
ie white and yes still the issue of
being able to be out in the family and
not wanting to lose the support of the
family by by rocking the boat at home so
was fiance Nigel and the couple's
friends except him in a way his family
does not the dancing goes on for hours
in the club on the champs London's East
End is a bright multi cultural area and
the British capital Whitechapel market
is where many Bangladeshi families do
their shopping I'm here to find out how
they feel about gay marriage becoming
legal
nearby I meet up with the asian women's
group most of the group's members are
homemakers Hindu and Muslim women from
Bangladesh and India together they
garden or go on excursions Sabet haahoos
Muslim also has a matchmaking agency a
service she provides for free they have
come to enjoy the weather she says it
isn't easy raising children and
grandchildren in a society with such
different values for in our culture the
priority was the house and the husband
now the girls they say we are educated
we are equal we have the same right as
men and so we want to be independent
they don't want to listen even my own
daughters and subhadra says she would
not consider arranging a marriage for
two partners of the same sex you can see
the difference it is embarrassing than
they are in the train or in the shopping
or they are just cuddling hugging the
same sex this year I like it when i see
identify I for the children it's not a
good sign area is not a good example you
noted my god but what about it this is
why they feel and they cannot change
only friendship friendly it's okay yeah
only married are under woman and man
children the girl got family life it's
nice yeah some some nails have female
hormones hormones predominant and some
females have predominant male hormones
the test torture I have forgotten the
name so they are they feel different and
even if you are looking the same and you
feel different then I think the society
should cater for you I'm sorry about the
society should cater for you in our
religion it is said that this gay
marriage is one of the sign of ending of
the world and that is why
most of the Muslims don't agree to it
right cheering when British lawmakers
move to give gay couples equal rights
Muslim groups and conservative
Christians try to stop them the equality
legislation passed but some religious
groups say they won't give up their
fight against us muhammad abdul bari is
a spokesman for the East London mosque
one of Europe's biggest when it comes to
homosexuality or gay marriage from the
religious point of view is not
acceptable in the faith tradition but
that doesn't mean that there should be
discriminated or they should be hated
there is no room for discrimination and
hate in any civilized society if people
want to change or debate on this issue
they should do it the Democratic civil
way I wondered how is it possible for
people to be part of a religious
community that rejects their love so I
met her began with SAR war he was a
practicing Muslim he still prays
regularly and won't touch alcohol the
apartments are war shares with his
fiance nigel is filled with the copos
memories and their favorite songs
just because
a photo taken by Nigel's mother so at
first I used to punish myself saying
it's my fault and used every religious
rituals do sort of cleanse myself but
then over time I realized I am Who I am
and then my religion is one aspect of my
life and the rest of me is the
restaurant one of my life so my
sexuality is true to me and I can't
change that and who the person are
careful in love for you know a is Nigel
sarwar says he doesn't care what Muslim
fundamentalist have to say about his
relationship it's not the religion
that's not accepting me it's more the
people who interpret the religion so I
I'm still you know my my faith is still
Islam but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
disown my religion a sunny day in
harringay in North London today one
couple here has overcome religious and
cultural barriers
sebald and niranjan are the first
same-sex Hindu couple to be married in
the borough their families come from Sri
Lanka and India where homosexuality is
still a crime I give you this free whoo
this room as a totem as a group of our
married life together married life
it's also a big day for suppose mother
although friends of the family say it
hasn't been easy for her dealing with
their relatives back in India even to
this day you know she's worried about
what the family have saved the snide
remark till yesterday she had a call
from a relative saying why are you
allowing this and if supports
grandparents were alive they would have
never let this happen so his mom turn on
and says well he's your family because
you're his aunt and she turn on and said
well you're his mom so you should put a
stop to it after the ceremony the
wedding party rides into soho in central
london to celebrate it's a chance for me
to have a chat with Sue bolds mother for
the past 17 years she's lived with her
son on his partner niranjan niranjan
takes care of her and she cooks for him
like a second son first time ago I heard
and I feeling so big and I cry I said
good what happened for me my world my
familia say did I after i started
exception now i am happy suppose mom
would you yes yeah a toast to the
couple's biggest supporter thank you he
doesn't need a straightforward and easy
journey me
I tell you what that's after this woman
really she's done with the wedding
couple has tried to be as inclusive as
possible they've even invited family
members who don't approve of their
relationship
all family members whether whatever
stage there at either their own personal
journeys of how they were how much they
will accept a same-sex relationship we
need to include them the process is
about encouraging and exchanging ideas
coming and working together it's only
once we include people who perhaps may
not understand that you can help to
change their opinions without that pecan
support and niranjan see themselves as
trailblazers they hope to see more
people in the future enjoying the same
freedoms they do whatever their gender
ethnicity or religion